does the network require that you submit
an outline before you start writing
sometimes it depends on the exec that
you're working with and it depends on
the producer sometimes the producer will
require it sometimes it's just we go
from one paragraph to one page sometimes
we go from one paragraph to a script it
whatever they want whatever makes them
feel comfortable in their process is
what I deliver to them what's the
typical show that you're writing for the
length of time that it takes me to write
it well or that what would be the
typical air time Oh so for most
television it's 83 to 86 minutes for a
feature okay so then what does that
translate into in terms of it depends on
the producer in terms of pages so you
know though the sort of the standard is
one page equals one minute of screen
time that's sort of a loose guide so I
have a producer I work with who won't
shoot anything under 116 pages because
he likes to have a lot of footage to cut
down to help the pacing I have other
producers I work with who they don't
want anything over a hundred pages so it
depends on their prop again their
production process so yeah interesting
yeah so I'm really getting the sense
that it's about flexibility it is yes
being flexible is is definitely a help
and and giving them what again giving
them what they want so many when I ask
producers why do you fire writers I ask
every producer I've worked with great
why do you fire writers and they will
always say because they don't give me
what I ask them to give me so it's
either notes they've given and then the
writer comes back and they haven't done
that with the notes because they thought
they knew better or they just didn't
know how or they asked for a certain
page count and it wasn't that page count
to me those are the wrong reasons to get
fired off of a project those are things
you can control so if you're just paying
attention and asking them what they want
and they want to tell you what they want
so I ask you know what do you want your
page lengths to be here where do you
want your ACK lengths to be and then
that's what I give on
Wow that's interesting so what's the
timeframe that you're usually given once
you've once they've given you the title
you've met with them you've come up with
some ideas what time frame are you
working with
it depends typically I get four weeks
for a first draft and then two weeks for
every subsequent draft which is it's
pretty quick actually it's not that
difficult if you're only working on one
project at a time but a lot of times
you'll you know if you're a working
writer you're working on multiple
projects because it takes so long before
one of them suddenly comes back and says
okay we're we're greenlit we can
actually move forward you don't know
when that's gonna happen so you know
you've got all these sort of irons in
the fire and then eventually one will
come back and sometimes to come back
which is great but now you have to
balance how you're gonna you know
deliver both of those scripts
you